[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم يقول ضيفنا الدكتور خالد فهمي
لما تولى رئاسه اللجنه المعنيه بتوثيق
الثوره المصريه عام 2011 والتي حلت نفسها
بعد عامين فقط يقول انا مؤرخ صنعت قراءه
التاريخ لذلك ساحاول الاجابه عن الاسئله
الملحه الحاضره بقراءه الماضي ليس لاربع
سنوات مضت فقط لكن بالتمعن في الجذور
العميقه للثورات التي تشهدها بلادنا وفي
محاوله فهم اسباب قيامها وفشلها ايضا وهذا
ما ميز مشروع فهمي في كتابه كل رجال
الباشا يذهب الرجل الى عمق المشكله ولا
ينشغل بتجلياتها وتمظهراتها فقط وفي
محاولته وطريقه لفهم ما جرى يرى ان ثمه
اسباب عميقه وقفت في وجه التحول
الديمقراطي المنشود في بلده منها الحقبه
الاستعماريه والتي لم يدخر الغرب فيها
جهدا لاجهاض كل موقف تحرري وجه خالد فهمي
كما يقول الباحثون عبر كتابه كل رجال
الباشا طلقه في وجه الروايه الرسميه التي
يتبناها مؤرخ الدوله المصريه والسائرون في
فلكها حول قيام دوله حديثه على يد محمد
علي باشا اذ انه رد على القول بان تاسيس
الدوله الحديثه في مصر تم بوعي كامل على
يد محمد علي باشا وانه كان يرى نفسه مصريا
وان قرار تاسيس الجيش المصري جاء في ظروف
لم يفكر خلالها الباشا ابدا بان يكون هذا
الجيش المصريين كما تدعي الروايه الرسميه
بل كان جيشا سلاليا خاصا بسلاله محمد علي
باشا ليحافظ عليها مشاهدينا الكرام قراءه
اخرى ومغايره ومختلفه للتاريخ وفهمه
والتاسيس عليه مع ضيفي المؤرخ الدكتور
خالد فهمي في الحلقه الثانيه فاهلا ومرحبا
بكم
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اهلا بكم
الى حلقه جديده من المقابله في الجزء
الثاني مع المؤرخ المصري البارز الدكتور
خالد فهمي مرحبا بك دكتور سعداء بوجودك في
هذه الحلقه الثانيه والتي تحاول قدر
الامكان انا ذكرت في الحلقه الاولى المؤرخ
يبذل جهدا عظيما
في مشروعه الفكري والتاريخي ونحن ايضا
نجري خلف المؤرخ لالتقاط بعض يعني بعض
مناطق الضوء هنا وهناك قال انه خالد فهمي
في في مشروعه الثقفي وجه طلقه للروايه
الرسميه حول الدوله المصريه ماذا تريد
تحديدا ايش اللي مش عاجبك في الدوله
المصريه او في في محاولتك لاعاده قراءه
تاريخ الدوله المصريه لا الدوله على عيني
وعلى راسي
انما السؤال هو
ده انجاز ضخم جدا انجاز تاسيس دوله مصريه
كفؤ وقويه ورسخه ده انجاز ضخم ويجب جميعا
كمصريين وكعب ان نتمسك به وندرك معناه
السؤال الذي احاول ان اطرحه هو
اولا كيف اسست هذه الدوله ثانيا الدوله
المصريه الحديثه على يد محمد علي باشا اه
وخلفائا وخلفائه لانه الدوله المصريه
الحديثه بدات مع مشروع محمد علي حتى
الدوله الحاليه اللي عند الدكتور انا
اعتذر المقاطع تؤرخ لنفسها مع بدايه مشروع
محمد علي ليس قبل ذلك
الى حد الى حد كبير ليس ليس
انه في قطيعه في ثوره قامت على النظام
الملكي ومع ذلك الجيش المصري يعتمد الان
الروايه له روايه الرسميه مع بدايه جيش
محمد علي باشا وانه هو الجيش المصري
الحديث لا الجيش المصري له روايه بيبداها
من الفراعنه هو بيحاول ان هو يؤسس لسرديه
تقول ان الجيش المصري مستمر من احمس او
يمكن من مينا موحد القطريين انما السؤال
المهم بغض النظر عن الجيش
كجيش مؤسسه الدوله العديده يعني البيوق
الشرطه هو
كيف اسست متى اسست ولكن ايضا
ما هي التكلفه التي اسست بها هذه الدوله
ومن هو الذي دفع تكلفه هذه هذا التاسيس
وسؤال اخر هو سؤال افتراضي
وبالمعنى وبهذا المعنى هو ليس سؤالا علميا
وهو هل كان يمكن اقامه هذه المؤسسات
بطريقه اخرى
فانا اتساءل يعني طبعا موضوع الدوله
المصريه ده موضوع كبير واحنا في ادبياتنا
الاكاديميه نتساءل عن طبيعه الدوله يعني
الدوله طبعا ليست مبنى
وليست شخص
وليست فكر فقط
الدوله هي مجموعه من التشابات والخطابات
والمؤسسات والممارسات والعلاقات ورؤى
الدوله يجب التعامل معها حتى ذهنيا وفكريا
بشكل نقدي يعني الكتابه كل رجال باشا انت
ذهبت فيه لمشروع محمد علي باشا لماذا قام
بهذا الامر في الاجزاء الاولى فصلتها في
هذا كان يريد اقامه حكم له ولاسرته اه
يعني انا
باشكك في مقوله ان محمد علي جاء بمشروع
فانا بقول يعني ده شخص يجب التعامل معه
بشكل تاريخي
لازم اعرف
اتتبعوا من مرحله الى اخرى من سنه الى
اخرى فانا لو بدات مع محمد علي اما جه مصر
كشاب عمره 30 سنه متى كانت المجيء الدكتور
في اي تاريخ سنه 1801 وطات قدماه وارض مصر
في مارس 1801
هو ولد في قوله في
ما هو الان اليونان كانت اقليم من اقاليم
الدوله العثمانيه جاء مع حمى عثمانيه بغرض
الطرد الفرنسيين من مصر
الحميه في الجيش كان ضابطا غير النظامين
هذا الجيش النظامي جاء من الشام الجيش غير
النظامي جاء من البحر من قوله فهو جاء مع
مجموعه من الالبانيين
والقوانيين
في قوه تعددها لا يزيد عن 4000 جندي هؤلاء
لم يكونوا جنودا مضاربين او فلاحين من من
من اقاليم الدوله العثمانيه
جاء سنه 1101 لا يتحدث العربيه
امي لم يدخل مدرسه لم يدخل كتاب لم يجيء
من قلب الدوله العثمانيه من اسطنبول من
اطراف من اطراف فقيره
ليس له راعي او كفيل في الدوله العثمانيه
ليس له حيثيه ليس من الاشراف
وليس غازيا يعني لم يدخل مصر بالسيف
وبعدين سنه 1101 الفرنسيين انهزموا ومشيوا
البريطانيين اللي كانوا جم يساعدوا
العثمانيين لطرد الفرنسيين هما الاخرون
رحلوا الجيش النظامي العثماني رحل بقي
الحميه الالبانيه التي جاء معها محمد علي
وبقي الجنود المماليك القدامى اصحاب
السطوه والجاه
القدامى في مصر هناك فراغ في السلطه
قدره او عظمه او ذكاء محمد علي هو ادراكه
وجود فراغه وجود فراغ وتعبئه هذا الفراغ
طبعا عبره
اشياء مختلفه ولكن الابقاء على شعره
معاويه مع الدوله العثمانيه مع الدوله
العثمانيه متى تولى السلطه تحديدا في
خمسه وانا في رايي على خلاف مؤرخين اخرين
ان مصدر شرعيته الاساسي لم يكن من الشارع
مصدر شرعياته الحقيقي فرمان عثمان اما
مصدر قوته هو الحميه الالبانيه التي كانت
كانها كانت جيش خاص بمحمد علي قوته داخل
المجتمع المصري الان هنا تولى السلطه محمد
كحاكم عثماني كحاكم عثماني مدرك انه مختلف
عن الحاكمين الحكام العثمانيين السابقين
لانه لم ياتي من قلب الدوله العثمانيه
وانه
عين على رغم او يعني على مضاده من حكم
الامر الواقع حكم الامر الواقع فكان يشعر
بالقلق بانه يمكن ان يزال من هذا وهذا اسس
لثقل لسلوك اتجاه الدوله العثمانيه اسس
لهاجس عميق هو في رايي هو مفتاح شخصيته
مش سهله محمد علي داهيه داهيه مش على
مستوى العالم على مصر او العالم العثماني
او العالم الاسلامي بس على مستوى العالم
[موسيقى]
ظل حلم انتزاع دمشق وعكا يداعب محمد علي
باشا الطامح في بناء جيش قوي يتكئ عليه في
بسط نفوذه الى حدود نهري دجله والفرات عزز
هذا الطموح عملا اولهما شعور محمد علي
باستحقاقه مكافاه على الخدمات الجليله
التي قدمها للدوله العثمانيه في انهاء
التمرد في الحجاز واخماد انتفاضه
اليونانيين اما العامل الثاني فتمثل في
بحثه عن ضمانات تدعم موقعه في مصر عبر
انشاء منطقه عازله بين قلب املاكه في وادي
النيل ومركز الدوله العثمانيه في الاناضول
اسندت مهمه ضم بلاد الشام الى حملتين بريه
وبحريه بقياده ابراهيم باشا نجلي محمد علي
وبالفعل تحركت في الثاني من نوفمبر من عام
1831 وكان قوامهما ثلاثين الف جندي
نجحت الحملتان وبسهوله في السيطره على
يافا ثم حيفا لتعلن على الفور كل من صيدا
وصور وبيروت وطرابلس واللاذقيه والقدس
ونابلس الولاء لابراهيم باشا سمحت هذه
الانتصارات المتتاليه بالتفرغ لمدينه عكا
الاستراتيجيه التي ضرب عليها حصار مكن من
فتحها بعد ان كانت قد استعصت سابقا على
نابليون بونابرت بعدها استولى ابراهيم
باشا على دمشق والحق هزائم فادحه بالجيش
العثماني تمكن على اثرها من ضم مدينتي
طرسوس واضما الاستراتيجيتين كما انتصر في
معركه حاسمه بالقرب من مدينه قونيا واسر
القائد العثماني لاحقا كانت معركه نسيب
التي تلقت فيها الدوله العثمانيه هزيمه
قاسيه كاد معها السلطان العثماني يرضخ
لمطالب محمد علي باشا متمثله بالاعتراف
بما جرى ضمه من مدن بلاد الشام لولا
تدخلات اوروبيه حملت الباشا على التنازل
عن تلك المدن مقابل ضمان ولايته الوراثيه
على مصر
محمد علي احد القاده الذين يؤرخ لفكرهم
وتجربتهم بالرغم من كل الاصول انه امي
لذلك بدا يتحدى الدوله العثمانيه اولها
بحمله الشعب طبعا 1830 لا هو بدا في
التعاون في الاول مع الدوله الدوله
العثمانيه على مضض وكلفته بالقضاء على
الحميه على القوى الوهابيه هذه كانت اول
حمله ابراهيم باشا حمله ابراهيم باشا سنه
1811 نجح فيها
كان دي مخاطره ان هو ياخدها خدها
واما نجح فيها
اكبر في في اسطنبول فاما فاندلعت الثوره
اليونانيه ضد الحكم العثماني السلطان
العثماني كلفه مره ثانيه بقمع الثوره
اليونانيه اذا هذا مشروع نجح فيها نجح
فيها ولكن حصل تحول في رايي مهم جدا في
شخصيته
اثناء الحميه
حمله ما نسميه حمله الموره من 1824 الالف
هناك
وجد نفسه يحارب قوى اوروبيه وجد نفسه
يتعامل مع
قوه تجاريه على امبرياليه على عسكريه
اوروبيه وان نزاعه او نزاع اليونانيين مع
الدوله العثمانيه لم يعد نزاعا داخليا
عثمانيا بل تعدى دوري لموضوع متوسطي ان لم
يكن اوروبيا واعتقد ان عظمته هو
لان الموضوع فرط ما غير فيه هذا الادراك
وهذا الحادث اعتقد انه هو بدا ينظر الى
نفسه على انه
يتحكم في قوه متوسطيه
يعني بمعنى قوه في البحر المتوسط هو الان
يتحكم في مصر والسؤال هو هل يمكن له ان
يتوسع شرقا
للشام والشام هي المفتاح الرئيسي خاصه في
امن مصر كان فرصه عظيمه او غريبه ان يتوسع
غربا للجزائر
الفرنسيين كانوا احتلوا الجزائر سنه 1130
تواصلوا معه
لمعاونتهم قبل الغزو سنه 29 هناك مكتبات
على احتلال الجزائر على احتلال الجزائر
ماذا كان موقفهما قال لهم لا
واعتقد ان هو قال لهم لا لانه كان مدرك ان
توسعه يجب ان يكون شرقا لانه عايز يامن
حدوده
من احتمال غزو عثماني يطيح به كان يشعر
بهذا القلق طول الوقت ليش طول الوقت وانا
اقرا لك ويعني في كتاباتها وقراءات سابقه
كانت دائما لديها لماذا
لانه كل الولاه المختلفين اللي حاولوا
يعملوا شيء زي اللي هو حاول يعمله وطيح
بيهم اهمهم كان علي باشا والياننا يانينا
في البانيا الان حاول بالضبط لمحمد علي
هؤلاء الولاه تاتي لحظه يخرجون عن السيطره
يصبحون قوه مستقله فتاتي دوله المركز
لازاحتهم خاصه السلطان محمود الثاني وهو
سلطان يحاول ان يؤكد من مركزيه المركز
فبالتالي كل الولاه ينخون هذا المنحه
الاستقلالي كانوا يطاح والرجل حكم مصر
فشعر به ايضا قوه يعني مصر دوله مركزيه
وكان وانجز فيها في
العقد الثاني من حكمه حتى العقد العقد
الاول والعقد الثاني انجازات لم يسبق مثل
مثل
تغيير نظام ملكيه الارض مثل استحداث زراعه
القطن وهو سلعه تجاريه ذات عائد ضخم جدا
مثل احتكار كل المحصولات الزراعيه
اعاده نظام الضريبي بشكل عام وبناء
بيروقراطيه حديثه طيب هذا لم يكن يعني
نفع على المجتمع المصري
لا في رايي ان المجتمع الفلاحين المصريين
اللي هو الجموع لشعب المصري لم يعد على
من ذلك عليهم باي شيء من النفع بالعكس هم
اللي دفعوا الثمن لانه سواء كان مزارعين
او عمال في المصانع عمال في المصانع كان
بيتاخدوا
كعبيد
بيربطوهم بسلاسل في في الالات
ونظام بوليسي صارم
يحكموه الالبان وغير المصري يحكموهم نخبه
النخبه اللي قدر ونجح محمد علي ان هو
يشكلها يا نخبه تتشكل من اعضاء اسرته
الحلقه القاضيه ثم اعضاء بلدياته من قول
او من اطراف الدوله العثمانيه المختلفين
ثم نخبه من الارمل
ثم مجموعه من الشوام
وكان رايه ان الطبقات لا يوجد مصريين
لادنى لا مش بس كده محمد علي واحنا شيء مش
منتبهين لمحمد علي عمره متوجه في كلام وفي
حديثه للمصريين مش بس عشان هو ما بيتكلمش
عربي هو ما تعلم عربي حتى في نهايه حياته
اه طبعا بيتعلم عربي كمسلم فهو حافظ
القران انما في حديث اليومي ما بيتكلمش
نتعامل يعني كيف هو يحكم مصر يستفيد من
مواردها البشريه والاقتصاديه يعني من مصر
يواجه العالم يواجه الدوله العثمانيه
يواجه البريطانيه اللاحقا فكيف كان ينظر
المصريين او مصر
هو قال يعني هو قال لي في حديث
بريطاني قال انتم عملتوا ايه في الهند
انتم عملتوا جيش في الهند ظباط وملي
الانجليزي
وجنوده من الهنود انا بعمل بالظبط اللي
انتم بتعملوه في الهند بعمله هنا في مصر
التركي بالنسبه له قصده العنصر التركي هو
الاصلح للقياده
العرب كانوا بيقولوا على المصريين اولاد
عرب اللي هم يتحدثون بالعربيه
لا يصلحون لشيء غير
يكونوا عبيد وادوات وادوات وده مش طبعا
بالنسبه لنا دلوقتي مستهجن وقتها ما كانش
مستهجم يعني معتاد عليه معتاد عليه وان
المصريين ما هو كانوا بيحكموهم مماليك
لقرون وهما مماليك مش مصريين لفتني دكتور
انه هو الان اصبح له حكم مصر فلماذا لم
يسعى ان يكون جزءا من مصر بشكل حقيقي حتى
ثقافيا يعني ده سؤال مهم جدا
داء في راي مربط الفرس وهو كان ممكن ممكن
يندمج ابراهيم باشا ابنه افضل منه كذا
نظرته للمصر والمصريين في مراسلات بينهم
انت تتحدث يعني
عندي تحفظات يعني اظن ابنه الاخر هو اللي
كان محبوب عند المصريين عند المصريين
وعنده تواصل حقيقي معهم طيب هو ليش ما عمل
هذا الشيء يعني لانه لانه كان عينه طول
الوقت مش على مصر على اوروبا لا على
اسطنبول الدوله العثمانيه على الدوله
العثمانيه او على لندن يعني يحاول استماله
لندن ويقول لهم بريطانيا قوه وهو جزء من
الدوله العثمانيه فهو بين هذه الثنائيه هو
ادرك قوه بريطانيا وادرك بيعمق
مدى اهميه مصالحها وادرك انه
مشروعه ايا كان هو ايه او قدرته على تحقيق
رغباته رغباته هو الاستئثار بمصر بشكل
دائم
وليس بشكل يجدد سنويا ويورث حكمه لاولاده
من اسطنبول سنوي سجدد له الحكم فهو كان
قلق من هذه المساله يريد ان يكون له الحكم
كامل حمله الشام 1830 صحيح وايضا كانت
مواجهه كبرى مع الدوله العثمانيه اه هو ده
يعني هو اصلا انه يصل اسطنبول بس يعني
برضو مهمه او حمله الشام بدات في خلينا
نفهم هذا الخط بدات في اكتوبر 1131 انا
رايي غرضها كان مجرد تامين حدوده الشماليه
ده من الشعب هي بوابه غزو مصر وقال انه
تضرع بانه في 6000 فلاح من الشرقيه
واقليم الشرقيه
هربوا الى الشام ولجاوا عشان ما يدفعوش
الضرائب الباهظه اللي كانوا لا عثمانيه
كانت هي مجموعه ولايات عثمانيه فبعث ابنه
على اساس انه هو يعني
بيامن الحدود
اهم طبعا عائق كان عكا قلعه عكا الحصينه
اللي استعصت على نابليون ابيب 30 سنه حاصر
عكا لمده خمس شهور او سته وفي الاخر فتحها
في مايو 1832
وممكن النظر لهذه المواجهه العثمانيه
العثمانيه على انها حرب اهليه عثمانيه حرب
اهليه ليست حربا بين دولتين يعني لم يجرؤ
على ان يستقل لا بشكل كامل ولا حتى فكريا
التحدي او الجزء الدرامي في ده انه حق ان
ابراهيم لقى نفسه بينتصر وبيلحق هزائم
فادحه في الدوله ما بيجيش ورا جيش ورا جيش
من جيوش الدوله العثمانيه اللي جيشها
السلطان محمود الثاني وبعدين في
ديسمبر 32
ابراهيم تخطى حدود الشام ودخل الى
الاناضول
مش هنبعث لك ولا معونه ولا بحريه ولا
عسكريه سنه 33
فاللعثمانيين استعانوا بالروس وبعدين
توصلوا مع محمد علي الى صلح بنسميه صلح
كتاهيه سنه 1133 وفضلت الامور في حاله ما
يريد محمد باشا محمد علي باشا
اخد شيء مهم جدا في هذا الصلح الذي استمر
الى اسابيع طويله اخذ كل الولايات
اللي كان يطمع فيها
اللي بقى بقى دلوقتي بيطنع فيها كل
الولايات العثمانيه
واقليم اضنه اقليم اضنه في اقصى جنوب شرق
في في يعني فوق اللاذقيه هذا اقليم غني
بغاباته
والغابات مهمه جدا للاسطور مصر تفتقر الى
الخشب
فده زي ما صدام يحتل ياخذ ادار البترول
السلطان كان ممتنع بس في الاخر ارغم على
اعطائه حق
التمركز في اقليم لماذا قبل محمد علي
التسويه يعني هل كان بامكانه ان لا يقبلها
وان يتوسع اكثر يحدث زلزالا في الدوله
العثمانيه السؤال ده طرح بعديها بسته سنين
اما حصلت الجوله الاخرى الاعمق في
المواجهات وانتصر مره اخرى على الدوله
العثمانيه في معركه نصيبين او نذيب في
يوليو سنه 1939
بعديها باسبوع واحد السلطان العثماني مات
بعديها باسبوع واحد الاسطول العثماني انشق
ووصل
لاسكندريه وقدم هديه لمحمد علي في الصف في
شهر واحد
محمد علي
قضى على الجيش العثماني
اغتنم الاسطول العثماني والسلطانه
العثماني مات كان فرصه مواطيه
اللي وقف قدامه كان الصدر الاعظم
خسروا غريموا من سنه 1801
اللي
استقوى بالدول الاوروبيه
الدول الاوروبيه غير موحده
في بذلت جهود مضنيه لتوحيد الدول
الاوروبيه عكس ما نقول ان هناك كان تواطئ
مسبق هذا كان تخطيط من شخص اخر اسمه مصطفى
رشيد ووزير الخارجيه
العثماني
لتوحيد القوى الاوروبيه وانشاء مؤتمر لندن
سنه 1840
اللي قالوا له
لمحمد علي لولو
انذارات انه لازم
يتنازل عن الاراضي التي احتلها انا في
رايي ان محمد علي
من ذكائه هو ادراك هذا ادراك قدراته انه
هذه حدوده هذه حدوده ويجب هنا ان اتوقف لو
تسمح لي
لتوضيح نقطه مهمه لان طبعا احنا كمصريين
احنا كعرب اما نقرا ونشوف مين مننا ما
يجيلوش حاله من الانتشاء انا لسه هحاول
عاوز اقول لك يا دكتور هذا الموضوع الجيش
كان مصري الجيش كان مصري بالمعنى ده يعني
الذي يحقق الانتصارات معظمه من المصريين
الجنود الجنود الضباط كلهم لا يوجد ضباط
مصري لكن القاعده الاساسيه جنود مصريه
مصريين وهذا عندك احتجاج عليه بعدين لانه
كان في اذل المصريه لكن كنموذج لرجل يبني
دوله وجيش وفي صراع تلك المرحله يعني
المهمه مع الدوله العثمانيه اوروبا وكان
ناجحه طبعا ده انجاز مهم جدا ان هو يعمل
هذه الاله العسكريه الجبارا وتحقق هذه
الانتصارات طبعا لا يمكن التقليل من اهميه
لكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم يعد شيئا على
المصريين صحيح بس لو نعود الى هذه اللحظه
الفارقه من سنه 39 لسنه 41 وانا اعمل الان
على كتابه سيره لمحمد علي وركز فيها
تحديدا على هذه السنوات الثلاث
في هذه السنوات الثلاث حصل تطور خطير جدا
في ادراك محمد علي وهو ادراكه لانه
احتفاظه بهذه الاراضي
مستحيل
بريطانيا وروسيا يعني
كان مدرج انه لو احتفظ
بهذه الاراضي هذا كان سيعني انهيار الدوله
العثمانيه وانهيار الدوله العثمانيه كان
سيحتم يتحتم عليه
حرب اوروبيه اوروبيه والاوروبيون غير
مستعدين لهذا
وفي نفس الوقت هم عرضوا عليه
عرض في رايي انه كان مهم وجيد له قالوا له
في نهايه المطاف
هندي لك مصر تحكمها مدى حياتك
ويحكمها ذريتك من بعدك بس في نظير ان انت
ترجع الاسطول وترجع الاراضي التي احتلتها
جيوشك اضنه وكذا والمناطق
والولايات الشاميه والحجاز واليمن
وترجعها فانا في رايي ان هو
شاف ان دي صفقه رابحه خاصه ودي النقطه
اللي الناس مش منتبهه لها ان مصر الدوله
اللي هو اسسها
الجهاز الاداري
غير قادره على التحكم في كل هذه الاراضي
يعني اضعف ما عندناش الكوادر الاداريه
يعني انا درست الاحتلال المصري للشام
مفيش سنه عدت من غير ثوره
الان انا اريد ان افهم انعكاس ذلك على مصر
الدوله ومصر المجتمع وهذا هو انشغالك
الرئيسي كل شيء عظيم نموذج لقائد عسكري
اسس لحكمه انت ترى ان كل هذا الامر لم يكن
له علاقه بمصر ولم يكن في وارد ان يتحدث
عن دوله مصريه او كان يريد ان ينشئ حكما
سلاليه حكما ملكيا لا هو لابنائه في الجسد
والحداثه انت دخلت في التفاصيل وفي الاذى
الذي وقع على على المصريين من خلال هذه
الاجراءات وانه لم يكن لم يكن مشروعا
مصريا
صحيح في جهاز اداري اسس انما تداعيات هذا
الجهاز الاداري
وده شيء يعني فعلا مبهر جهاز الدوله اما
نفكر فيه بيتعمل ازاي في بؤخرطيه وفي
تدريب للبيوقراطيين في اسلوب ماسك الدفاتر
في لايحه معاشات في مكافات
في كل ده كان في اداره عفويه يعني كان في
مهام انه فلان وهي دوله اصلا دوله محمد
علي بدات كده انه يروح لخالد يقول له خالد
امسك لي الاقليم ده القريه هذه عندك او
القريه دي فييجي خالد يقول له طيب انا
ضمنت مش بس سنه او اثنين انت مديني ده
لمده طويل ماشي طب انا عايز كتب عايز مكان
مبنى عايز قواعد امشي بيها عايز قواعد
اجرائيه وقواعد عقابيه
وبشويه بالسجون سجون تجنيد لاحقا مش بس
السجون للفلاحين لا سجون الموظفين
الموضوع انه الفلاحين هم اللي جنده طب ما
هم الفلاحين الفرنسيين برضو جنده
والفراحين الفرنسيين زي الفلاحين المصريين
برده ولا مش مش متعلمين واميين ومش فاهمين
المشروع العظيم بتاع القائد اللي اسمه
نابليون ماشي انما في همزه وصل هما القاده
الكبار
ونابليون برضو زي محمد علي هو مش فرنسي هو
من كوسكا هو برضو مختلف اثنيا عن جموع
الفرنسيين
من عظمه نابليون ايه ان سنه 1810 عمل
الامبراطوريه عمل جوه الجيش منصب جديد دار
عمل 24 18 منصب جديد اسمه
اما نبص في في
الخلفيه بتاعه 18 مارشال 14 منهم ولاد
فلاحين
الاربعه المتبقين هم الاستقراض بس كان هذا
بوعي وبتعمد هذا اللي ما عمله محمد علي
باشا ليش لانه مش اكره
المصريين وحاسس انه هو هم لانه في حاجه مش
موجوده في فرنسا الحاجه اللي مش موجوده في
فرنسا هو الاطار العثماني
في بعد عثماني مش موجود في فرنسا مصر في
النهايه كانت جزء من الدوله العثمانيه
فبالتالي هو يعني يستعين باي مورد ضمن
الدوله العثمانيه ليس بالضروره من بالضبط
من مصر ليس ازدراء مطلقا بالضبط هو ما
عندوش اكفاء مثلا من البانيا من كذا
فنستعينهم وعندهم ولاءات
لاحقا حينما استطاع ان يرسم حدود مع
الدوله العثمانيه وان يبني ملكه الشخصيه
والعائلي والسلاليه لم ترد ايضا فكره
تطوير المصري والاستفاده منهم العمل ده هو
سعيد حفيد ابنه اللي جه بعد بعد عباس اللي
هو اول مره يبقى مصريين يرقوا الى مناصب
قياديه في الجيش
لفكره اللي هي الخنوع المصري يا دكتور انه
هيك هذا القبول ما كان في تحدي بمعنى انه
هذه ارضنا وهذا اجنبي وان كان طبعا
السياقات التاريخة مختلفه كان مسلما
وعثمانيا وهم جزء من الدوله بس ما كان في
تحدي بمعنى الرغبه باختراق طبقي لا ما هو
انا في رايي هي ثوره وربي كانت ايه ثوره
ورابي
وضباط عرابي هم كانوا
يعني نتيجه حتميه لهذا السخط الشعر يعني
تقريبا يعني
جيل واحد يعني
بدايه ترقي المصريين في الخمسينات
او نقول جيلين من وقت وفاه محمد علي متى
توفي
1849 يعني تنازل عن الحكم الاسباب مرضيه
1848 السنه السابقه
وحكم حفيد وعباس وبعدين ابنه سعيد لان
حفيدو كان اكبر من ابنه
ثوره اوروبي كانت اول تحدي الجيل الثاني
كان اول تحدي وهو نتاج او رد على سؤال
حضرتك ليه المصريين المصريين قاموا
بالثوره اعتراضا تحديدا على سياسه عزلهم
وعدم ترقيهم بشكل كبير هذا ترقيه موقع
قيادي طبعا الدراما المصريه انه لما حصلت
الثوره دي هي انتهت باحتلال مصر من قبل
بريطانيا يعني بقى في خلصنا من الدوله
العثمانيه ومن الاستبداد المحلي انما
انتهينا باحتلال اجنبي برده نتيجه تواطؤ
الحاكم الخديوي اللي هو قال للانجليز
تعالوا احموني من شعبي
لم يقرر تقرر ثلاث سلاله محمد علي ان تكون
مصريه في لحظه ما لا هي ولا قرات متاخره
هي ومش مساله قرار هو مساله يعني تمصير
بيحصل بمرور الوقت يعني هذه السلاله هذه
النخبه العثمانيه بيتكلموا تركي بيصيفوا
في تركيا عندهم قصور في اسطنبول عندهم
اراضي في اسطنبول
بمرور الوقت تزوجوا من مصريين ومن مصريات
اكتسبوا العربيه ابتدوا ان هم
يمتلكوا اراضي في مصر مش في الدوله
العثمانيه وابتدوا يعني
يرسوا قواعد لهم
كاسر كعائلات وكاشخاص في مصر ومن اهمها
الاوقاف عملوا اوقاف لهم تحمي املكهم
في مصر
انت دكتور في ايضا مشاريعك الكتابيه ذهبت
الى تاريخ المهمشين معنى انه تحاول ان
تفهم الدوله تفهم
الاحداث التاريخيه من خلال تاريخ المهمشين
وهذا هذه مدرسه حديثه يعني هذا هذا امر
جديد يحدث في الدراسات التاريخيه دائما
تدرس المجتمعات والدول من دراسه قادتها
ودراسه انظمتها الحاكمه فانت درست
المصريين
نفتح قصه المصري
هؤلاء المهمشين في بلدهم يعني انا بدات
هذا المنحى من الاول خالص من كتاب كل رجال
البشر اللي هو كان اطروحه الدكتوراه وكان
السؤال المنهجي هو هل يمكن قراءه او كتابه
تاريخ الجيش ليس من اللي احنا حكيناه يعني
ده معروف اللي هو محمد علي وابراهيم
والعثمانين هل لو غيرنا النظر زاويه النظر
نشوف الفلاح المصري اللي اتخرط في الجيش
ده لو كان بيحكي قصته كان هيحكيها ازاي
طبعا ده سؤال منهجيا صعب لان ما عندناش
مصادر من كتبها الفلاحين دول
فده كان التحدي الاكبر وهو هي طبعا مدرسه
مختلفه مش بس انا ما بداتهاش
لكن سرتها على طريقها وفي زمايل يعني ماذا
فعلت لكي تعرف او تؤرق من زاويه المهمه
اولا كنت محظوظ ان في دار الوثائق القوميه
في سجلات حمله الشام تحديدا في محاكمات
عسكريه للجنود مش بس ظباط ففي الجنود في
السجل المحاكمه في كلا في كلام فسمعنا
الفلاح المصري هو طبعا ده مش خطاب
بيوسري فيه بنفسه لمثلا والدته هو متهم
ويجيب على اسئله محقق يعني فبالتالي لازم
نستطيع ان نقرا له شيء
من من تلمس صوت الجندي هو تلمس
يعني هو هو البناء بناء الكتاب بناء يعني
فانا تخيلت لو انا عندي فرصه التحدث مع
الجندي مش مع محمد علي قلت له احكي لي
قصتك في في الجيش مش هيقول ان محمد علي
جاه مصر سنه 1801 هيقول انا كنت قاعد في
قريتي وبعدين جم خدوني وجندوني وضربوني
وبعتوني وبعدين صار في تطعيم صار في
اجراءات طبيه وصار في اجراء اتخيل هو
هيقول ايه وبالتالي بناء الكتاب نفسه هو
بدا بفصل عن التجنيد وبعدين فصل عن
التدريب وبعدين فصل عن المعركه وانفصل عن
تابعات المعركه كانه الجندي هو اللي بيحكي
فانا تخيل المدخل الاساسي اللي فاهم
المصريين في رجال ثم تطور الامر ثم تطور
قبل ما يتطور بس ماذا وجدته في في بحثك في
هذه المسائل تحديده يعني ما هي زاويه
النظر الجديده لكل ما جر انه اولا انه كل
الممارسات الحديثه دي سواء كان التطعيم ضد
الجدري او التجنيد او استحداث زراعه القطن
او
اجراءات الحجر الصحي او المستشفيات
الحديثه او المصانع الحديثه او المدارس
الحديثه قصر العيني والكذا اشياء كثيره كل
الاشياء دي احنا هنعرفها الطريقه
التقليديه اللي احنا بندرس بها ده انه ده
شيء اسمه حداثه هذا بدايه الحداثه في مصر
تمت على يد محمد علي وعندنا مجتمع
خامل او
غارق في غياهب الجهل
بالذات لما نتكلم على الدوله وعثمانيه على
انها دوله متخلفه وكده وحصلت المواجهه
وطبعا الجزء
الفكري فيها او الطريقه التقليديه ان في
فكر اوروبي جاي على مجتمع اسلامي انا كنت
عايز اشكك في الثنائيه دي وان انا اقول
انه يمكن مش دي الطريقه الامثل لفهم الناس
مش مش الطهطاوي ومش محمد علي بس الفلاح
العادي الفلاح العادي بالنسبه له موضوع
الهويه مش مش طاغي عليه هو بيشوف التجنيد
ده هيفيد ولا لا
المستشفى الجديده دي هتفيده ولا لا القطن
اللي هو بيسرع ده هيجني منه ايه
وانا في
مدخلي لفهم الدنيا مش بس التاريخ هو ان
انا اؤمن بقدره الشخص على قراءه واقعه
وانه اعتقد باهميه العقل
والرشد وان الناس اقدر ناس الناس العاديه
بفهم مصلحتها فانا بحاول اتلمس رد فعل
الناس كان ايه
لهذه الممارسات
فرايي ان هم ما رفضوش الحداثه الاوروبيه
بمجملها وما اقبلوش عليها بمجملها هم
بيعملوا حسبه عقلانيه فانتجنيد في رايي
رفضوه
التطعيم رفضوه في الاول وبعدين قبلوه
لاسباب مختلفه ملهاش علاقه بالطب والعلم
لها علاقه هل انا هستفيد بده ولا لا
وبعدين
لها علاقه كمان بالتخوف المتبادل بين
المصري والدوله الوليده دي لا يوجد ثقه لا
يوجد ثقه لانها يعني لا تعبر عنه وانها مش
وليده منه مش طالعه مصريه كان اقصد طبقه
الحكم المصريه لكان الامر اكثر يسرا او
حتى لو كان ما هو في دول كثيره القاده
بتوعهم مش في اجراءات ثقه في ايجارات ما
كان في اجراء
لبناء المصريه ففي فالناس مش مساله ان هم
يعني غارقين في الجهل الناس عندهم اسباب
عميقه جدا للتوجه من الدوله دي اما
بيلاقوا وده كتابي السعي العداله انه حتى
الممارسات اللي هي كان اصلها الغرض منها
وخدمه الدوله لو هي ممكن ان انا استفيد
منها ممكن نعمل ديل صفقه بالزبط وهذه
طبيعه البشر بالضبط
انت عندك احتجاج على فكره انه هو جلب
الحداثه لمصر
انا انا يعني انا عشان شايف ان هو اصلا
مشروع وما كانش مشروع حداثي هو مشروع
تاسيس حكم اسري ليه تداعيات ليه
جوانب مضطر
لتطوير طبي بالضبط فقهي قانوني
عسكري الى اخره والناس بيلمسه ده بمعنى
حرفي الحاجات دي بتلمس اجسادهم عشان كده
انا مسمي الكتاب جسد والحداثه ومدخلي
لكتاب السعي للعداله هو مدخل حواس عندي
خمس حواس بدات بالنظر والسمع والشم وكل
شيء وكان الغرض من ده هو التاكيد على
مركزيه
الحواس ومركزيه الجسد وان احنا ما نعملش
اسقاطات ايديولوجيه على الواقع
محمد علي باشا لم يكن لصاحب مشروع مصري
صاحب مشروع سلالي اسري عظمه ذاتيه كان
يتباهى امام الغربيين اللي يزورون يعمل
المسرحيات والضوء الشمعي يجي كذا على
عيونه يعني حركاته والغرب طبعا اللي جاي
ده يعني في اوجه الاستشراق عنده نظره
دونيه
لشعب متخلف بالزبط وانه زي دلوقتي الغرب
بيلهث وراء فكره المستبد العادل ان احنا
عايزين شيء شخص نقدر نعتمد عليه
وما يتفرطش العقد منه يعني عنده السيطره
ويكون مستنير وفق المقاييس الاوروبيه او
الغربيه فهو كان عارف ده وبيعرف يلعب على
الوتر ده عشان يقول لهم انا رجولكم الافضل
اعتمدوا علي انا وهو ممكن يفكر في نزاعه
مع السلطان العثماني بالظبط على ده هو راي
العام
المبتغى
والمقصود الاوروبي
حديثه الطويل هذه التفاصيل العصر
الليبرالي احنا اليوم الليبراليين العربي
دكتور ويقول لك والله مصر ايام الملكيه
كانت ليبراليه وتعيش عصر ذهبي والجنيه كان
فيها يعني سعره كذا وهذه صوره مسيطره
انت تقول له عصر لا ليبرالي ولا ذهبي
لا انا يعني خالد فهمي اللي يقولها لا
اسلامي ولا شيء يعني مؤرخ من خلفيه
علمانيه انا انا بقول انه خلينا برضو ننظر
للموضوع
بمعايير اللحظه دي احنا كان عندنا
انتخابات وكان عندنا صحافه مزدهره وكان
عندنا سينما
وحركه نشر مزدهره وكان عندنا
نظام ملكي مستقر الى حد الى حد
بس كان عندنا احتلال انجليزي طب كل الدول
كثيره كانت محتله يعني بس
فبالتالي وكان عندنا
قمح للحركه النقابيه شديد
وتخوف جاي من تخوف الانجليز بعد الثوره
البلشفيه من اي نشاط شيوعي في مصر ووقت
لاي محاولات تنظيميه
وده شيء الوفد انخرط فيه
والقصر طبعا انخرط فيه وده اللي سمح لحركه
زي
الاخوان المسلمين ان هي تملا الفراغ ده
يعني
اما نتكلم عن لحظه ليبراليه او فتره
الليبراليه لازم ناخد في عين الاعتبار
الكوامل الفاشيه اللي موجوده فيه في اتجاه
فاشي جوه الدوله جوه المجتمع المصري
حركه الاخوان جزء منه
مصر الفتاه جزء منه وكان اللي ممكن يتصدى
لهذا الاتجاه الفاشي هو اتجاه يساري اتجاه
شيوعي او التنظيمات نقابيه عماليه دي وادت
فبالتالي انا حكمي على الفتره الليبراليه
مش بس ان كان في انتخابات ان الصوره لم
تكتمل التوازن لم يكن موجوده صحيح انه تم
الغاء ضلع اساسي يعمل التوازن وبرضو ان
احنا ننتبه للناس مش بس للنخب ننتبه للناس
وتنظيماتهم لان احنا دلوقتي بنتكلم على
ميه سنه بعد تجربه محمد علي فاحنا عندنا
دلوقتي ارهاصات لنقابات مستقله عندنا اول
ادراج للعمال في مصر سنه 1899 عندنا حركه
عماليه كانت ممكن تزدهر لان في قاعده
صناعيه موجوده
وفي رايي عدم وجود هذا الاتجاه هو اللي
فتح المجال الاتجاهات الفاشيه اللي في
الاول الاخوان مسكوها
ملقوا الفراغ ده وبعدين العسكر جم سنه 52
كل ده في ظل وجود تحكم اوروبي ماذا جرى في
يوليو في الدوله المصريه ما التغير الذي
حدث
التغير هو اعاده
اعاده مركزه
السلطه اللي كانت موجوده بشكل كبير في
القصر الملكي على حسب دستور 23
واحالتها الى
رئيس الجمهوريه اللي هو بعد كده بقى عبد
الناصر من سنه 56 وطالع
وبعدين تفكيك زي ما قلنا قبل كده تفكيك
المؤسسات اللي كانت موجوده يعني اللي حصل
للصحافه وتاميمها اللي حصل للنقابات
وتاميمها ضرب الجامعات
وتجريف
الحياه الجماعيه يعني مقارنه بالمواقف
المشرفه اللي وقفها طه حسين حركه 9 مارس
في التلاتينات
مين مين كان يقدر يعمل ده وقت عبد الناصر
ويقول انه
يوقف
التدخل
القوي من قبل الجهاز الاداري للدوله في
الحركه في الحياه الجماعيه المصريه
باسم الثوره وباسم المكتسبات الاشتراكيه
اللي عملها محمد عبد الناصر
حصلت صفقه جديده مع
الشعب المصري
عبد الناصر ونزامه قال لهم قال لنا
كمصريين هنديكم حقوق اقتصاديه واجتماعيه
في نظير التخلي عن حقوقكم الدستوريه
وسياسيه واحنا قابلنا بده شكرا للمؤرخ
المصري الدكتور خالد فهمي الشكر موصل لكم
انتم مشاهدينا الكرام على طيب المتابعه
القاكم ان شاء الله في حلقات مقبله دمتم
بخير وفي امان الله
[موسيقى]